What's up guys, Helen here,
wondering how long it's been since I partied share to drink or just hugged
somebody I don't live with. Of course, if you're a resident of the hype house,
the answer is five seconds ago.
And also you just stuck your tongue in a stranger's mouth.
Indeed amidst the cultural backlash of the pandemic.
A certain class of famous people online influencers have reached new Heights of
media attention simply by refusing to stay the hell home.
But even before the unplanned demic hit online,
influencers have been settling dabbing, lip, sinking unboxing,
and pranking their way into increasingly bigger spotlights all while rewriting
the rules of 21st century celebrity they're often dismissed as not deserving
fame or being grossly self-promoting or for being very bad people who are
officially uninvited to my birthday party. But as tech talk star,
Charlie Emilio's recent ascendance to the big screen of the Dunkin donuts menu
proves that's not stopping them. So how did we end up here?
What's the deal are influencers,
just a slightly different form of celebrity or something more nefarious going
on. Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on influencers,
what went wrong. But first in true influencer fashion,
we wanted to do a little self promo.
Right now you can grab the t-shirt I'm wearing and a bunch of other cool designs
on the wisecrack store. We just did a big update.
So even if you visited before, now's the time to check it out. We have dad hats,
long sleeves t-shirts and even these funky mugs wrap your faith philosophy
channel in style by visiting wisecrack,
that store or hitting the first link in the description.
We appreciate your support. Yeah. And hope you like the new merge.
Now back to the show, this might not be a shocker, but fame is not new.
There's something unique about how fame became live, streaming yourself,
lighting your mattress on fire.
We're terrorizing the people of Tokyo with an octopus tentacle and to figure out
why we need to talk about this guy, Alexander, the third of Mastodon,
or as you know him, Alexander the great this fourth century King was great.
Not because he dropped 200 racks on this car at the age of nine, but instead,
because he created the world's largest empire in just 13 years, but a scholar,
Leo Brody writes in his book, the frenzy of renown fame and its history.
That's not why we still know his name.
It's because he was the first famous person.
How did this smelly warrior rise above all the Kings before and after him while
our boy Alex had an almost superhuman craving for more land,
he also had the Cunnington know that the most valuable real estate was in the
minds of those.
He ruled he was obsessed with carefully cultivating his reputation,
claiming to be descended from the gods and modeling himself after the brave
warriors from Homer's poetry in Athens,
he was officially named a God and not just in a Morgan Freeman kind of way.
And in some ways, Alexander nailed the basics of fame that persist to this day,
like Billy McFarland, inviting hot people to fire Island,
Alexander understood the importance of visual representation.
That's always been crucial to fame because if people are going to worship you,
they generally have to know approximately what you look like.
If you're tracking the evolution of celebrities,
it helps to look at the visual mediums that define them in the public eye.
Alexander was super picky about how he was portrayed visually only allowing his
three favorite artists to depict him from life. They typically did.
So in a way that evoked Helios the sun, God,
because ancient Greece wasn't the time for modesty.
And whereas coins were once the exclusive realm of gods and mythical heroes,
Alexander was the first to stamp his own pretty face on currency.
So sure Alexander was a legend,
but he was also kind of a regular dude who ate with his troops and fought
alongside them. This is another theme we'll see throughout our history of fame.
Famous people are often larger than life yet also relatable folks.
You can share a beer or a goblet with his legacy.
As a conqueror was cemented.
As he spawned the first ever wave of biographic books.
Here was a guy whose story was truly worth telling,
but Alexander wasn't alone in his early fame,
ancient Greek and Roman culture was full of fame, hungry folks,
doing impressive things to inspire poets, to write about them. But in Rome,
in particular,
everything was about performance and leading a public life in the name of
personal glory and civic duty.
The writer Cicero even tried to pen an Epic poem about himself,
deeply charismatic Roman leader,
Julius Caesar outdid the rest with his obsession with triumphant parades and
elaborate gladiator shows.
What's more Cesar was the first soldier to write a narrative war memoir.
And apparently as he laid dying,
rearranged his Toga as one final act of image control. Now,
Caesar was not an influencer selling.
His bathwater that we know.
That's partly because consumer society was still a millennia or two away.
And at this time, celebrity was mostly about big men doing big things, you know,
conquering and leading and so forth. But as culture has changed,
so would fame and keep in mind fame hasn't consistently been in Vogue.
That's thanks mostly to this guy who switched things up in the first century,
a D by living humbly avoiding publicity and promising mad glory in the
afterlife. Naturally celebrity culture took a bit of a dip,
but certainly didn't disappear.
And fame would eventually smash through the confines set by Christianity and
further expand beyond Kings and rulers with the Renaissance.
See the Renaissance brought the rise of portrait painting and the printed page,
both of which began circulating images of people all over Europe.
This moment was all about the individual and with that his or her fame
as Brody puts it.
Everyone who made a career in public was being made to realize how both art and
printing could make it more symbolic, more essential and more powerful.
What's more portrait seem to scratch that itch that everyone has to be
remembered and to have their individual essence captured as Leon Battista
Alberti wrote in the 15th century, the face of a man who was already dead,
certainly lives a long life through painting.
This frenzy meant the rise of more and more people being memorialized with a
paintbrush. The best example though, still comes from a Monarch queen Elizabeth.
The first of England who was self-consciously curating her brand more than 400
years before you downloaded Bisco in a turbulent time,
Elizabeth fiercely controlled her own image,
sending out pre-approved portraits all over the kingdom to be copied by
artisans.
She even issued a proclamation to have all unapproved paintings destroyed
though.
It apparently wasn't enforced while monarchs weren't sponsored by red bull. The,
um,
bold fashion choices of royalty certainly trickled down through the aristocracy.
If the Renaissance expanded access to fame beyond Kings and Queens,
the 18th century absolutely exploded it.
The combined French and American revolutions trumpeted,
the democratic man and the slew of such men like the founding fathers were
thoroughly obsessed with their legacy. Likewise,
post revolutionary war Americans were eager to celebrate them with dumb legends
like that. Cherry tree thing in America.
Celebrity has always been far more democratic centering itself around the
individual who seems to possess that special spark, a spark,
which simultaneously the spectator could believe that they to possess.
And so not unlike any given selfie challenge portraits depicted the so-called
democratic man via images like this of the low key homely, Ben Franklin,
meanwhile books, pamphlets, portraits, and caricatures circulated like mad,
bringing evermore faces and writings to the masses and providing evermore
avenues for fame, concurrently fandom. As we know,
it really started to begin as philosopher. John jock,
Russo grumpily recounted people who had never read his books would come from
miles away to gab with the man famous for his intellect,
strangeness and striking adoption of Armenian fashion.
Needless to say ever enjoyed these conversations,
still imitating the look of your favorite French philosopher.
It wasn't possible for most people until the 19th century when the industry sure
revolution brought the fast,
cheap mass production of imagery and of ready-made clothes, shoes, cigarettes,
et cetera,
fashion suddenly took off whole new layer that of personal identity
and folks often dress to impress by copying images of famous people.
They get their hair cut like Lord Byron, or wear gloves like prime minister,
Benjamin Disraeli and coincidentally,
this brought about first the rise of the Nandy due to dress like famous
aristocrats,
even though they often weren't and a huge number of people being brought to
insane asylums for claiming to be Napoleon still. When it came to fame,
the most profound change of the century was the arrival of photography,
which democratize the right to see your own sexy on paper.
It said that Lincoln credits his success as much to a widely circulated
photograph of him as he did to any awesome speech he ever gave the photograph,
made him both accessible and someone to emulate the simultaneous rise of
journalism provided a place to celebrate the newly anointed masses of the famous
and the arrival of gossip columns.
Let you find out what your favorite general was eating or what snarky things he
was saying about his enemies in this way, by the end of the 19th century,
celebrity had basically stopped being primarily about heroic achievements,
like an Alexander the Great's case, and started to really be about identity,
how that identity is expressed and how it can be mimicked by adoring fans.
Like when queen Victoria popularize the poofy white wedding dress that for some
inexplicable reason is still with us today. At this point,
there were more ways to become famous than ever before,
but one development would blow our concepts of celebrity out of the water,
the rise of the motion picture. Well,
early film actors weren't even named in the credits.
It only took 14 years for a bonafide star system to form.
Whereas theater actors had been achieving various amounts of fame.
Since the 16th century,
the movie actor was something different projected on a giant screen,
their emotions and their individuality were far more accessible.
And people felt instantly in love,
much the way they would with YouTube star and pathological tattoo collector.
Justin Bieber her much of Hollywood history, most famous stars were women,
and they were mostly naturalistic performers appearing to portray themselves on
screen and portraying sensationalized versions of themselves in the gossip
columns. As a result,
the connection between an early movie fan and their favorite star was intimate,
almost possessive.
It's no wonder that movie stars soon began to have their clothes ripped by mobs
of rabid fans. What's more because anybody can technically play themselves.
Movies made the most glamorous kind of celebrity seemed like it was just one
killer audition away, further democratizing our collective concept of fame.
According to movie critic and author Burr above all the movies propagated,
the idea that you didn't really matter unless you were seen and seen,
they were Charlie Chaplin emerged as one of the first worldwide recognizable
faces his trans continental railway tour attracting mobs of adoring fans,
notably and uniquely Charlie made eye contact in his films as if to
emphasize his own accessibility to the audience.
Still most movie stars were both relatable and inaccessible in their glimmer
people.
You could go to the theater and dream of emulating and as they did consumer
spending and the leisure industry exploded as more and more people used
commodities and personal style to imitate the stars.
This wasn't some random by-product consumption is key to the idea of the
modern celebrity as P David Marshall puts it.
Celebrity taught generations how to engage and use consumer culture to make
this was literalized in the form of celebrity endorsement,
which began to really boom in the 1920s,
subsequently every development that affected the film industry from the rise of
the talking picture to the rise of people,
magazine to the rise of hell on earth has brought stars closer to us,
making them more accessible,
but perhaps nothing changed the possibilities of celebrity more than this.
Good thing. It turned on that TV. Lisa that's right.
Wait the television. While the big screen bred reliably glamorous stars,
TV, which rapidly took over America,
provided the space for a different kind of celebrity.
The TV star was even more accessible and democratized.
The regularity of television programs,
bred familiarity intensifying.
The sense that you really know the star is a person most emblematic of early TV.
Fame is Lucille ball.
A then B list movie actress who was a non Hollywood approved 40 years old when
her show started.
I love Lucy was about a woman who wanted to be a star thus as Burr
explains,
it explored the distance between the average person and fame and the pain of
that desire for celebrity coming up short,
such themes were doubtless very relatable to an America,
still absorbing the implications of Hollywood fame.
But as TV contributed to the destruction of the studio system,
we also saw the parallel rise of new Hollywood and with it,
the quote unquote common man in film exemplified by the likes of Dustin Hoffman
and gene Hackman,
we'd come a long way since the most famous people were Kings and Queens as
famous came entirely about being watchable.
Celebrity became an accessible dream for anyone with that special something.
But the single biggest step in this process may have been the arrival of reality
television developed in the late 1980s when TV studios were slashing
costs,
reality TV emerged as a cheap production model that banked on nameless talent.
But by the early odds, it was dominating the medium beginning,
a cycle of everyday people being made famous before being cast aside for the
next set of freshly tan faces.
If a glamorous silent movie star inspired the desire to imitate and the more
accessible Lucy inspired relate-ability reality,
TV inspired a more total identification with the stars in front of us.
They formerly nobodies we're. Now somebody on our screens,
they exemplified the paradox of celebrity being extraordinary wellbeing,
totally ordinary. And unlike being born, the son of Phillip of Mastodon,
anyone could allegedly end up being.
I met him through a good neutral friend of mine, a grinder.
Most importantly, reality TV confirmed the suspicions.
Each of us secretly harbors that we deserve fame too.
And what's more that we could achieve it. If only we could dance saying,
or sit in a giant walk of ice in a compelling way, scholar, Mark,
Andrea Vick argues that ironically,
the increased democratization of fame after this a convenient collective fantasy
during a time of increasing economic inequality,
the idea that we could strike it rich on the voice was a cheery antidote to the
fact that we can barely afford rent.
But before fame could turn into watching Tauna mojo, self emulated,
her dumb boot, late VidCon, there was still one step left.
We had to not only aspire to celebrity,
we had to become obsessed with the process of celebrity making, you know,
like watching a viral star shoot to fame before ruining his young career by
making fun of a dead guy in a Fort.
Well, did we just find a dead person in the suicide forest.
And then watching the train wreck of that person continually trying to revive
their career with PR stunts.
This is what scholar Tim mole calls a hypertrophic celebrity culture.
That is to say a culture in which we're far more obsessed with,
say the process of the Pauls or the Kardashians becoming famous and the
mechanisms of how they achieve that fame than we are with any one particular
celebrity.
This process is literally baked into the model of most popular reality shows
like American idol or the voice, or America's next top model.
And so on in this era,
celebrities like the Kardashians become more admired for their shrewd image
control for how they handle and enhance their celebrity than for any other
talents or abilities. I'd still don't understand how Paris Hilton got so famous.
But by asking that very question,
I'm probably contributing to this hypertrophic celebrity culture, of course,
watching the process of a normie or a hotel,
era's become a capital C celebrity got a lot easier with the widespread use of
the internet. And later social media, since then college student,
Jennifer Ringley finagled a so-called Jenny cam that took pictures of her room
every three minutes, basically inventing blogging.
The internet has increasingly become a space for staging our everyday lives even
more so than the idea that anyone is one audition away from fame.
The internet has brought us the idea that any one is one tick talker,
long away from the highest echelons of internet startup.
The internet also offers the potential for the micro celebrity.
That is someone who is extremely famous to a very specific group of people like
makeup or gaming enthusiasts.
Whereas we've always suspected that film stars were playing a perhaps heightened
version of themselves on screen internet start-up is predicated on a strangely
performative sense of authenticity fittingly.
Some of the biggest stars of the internet era from the Paul brothers to the mojo
sisters are ordinary everyday.
People who happen to be good at playing themselves and happened to become famous
for it because of this supposedly authenticity,
more so than any celebrity before them influencers cultivate an intense pair of
social relationship with fans.
That is a one-sided relationship in which the fan gives love,
likes an emotional investment while the famous guy gives very little in return
other than an occasional thank you to my fans authenticity.
Plus the strength of the parasocial relationship happens to make influencers
perhaps more so than glamorous movie stars. Excellent salespeople,
particularly when it comes to chicken nugget pillows.
It's no wonder every corporation from Adidas to McDonald's has taken note.
Fittingly influencers are also the embodiment of this hypertrophic celebrity
culture,
where your success at achieving fame in the form of views or followers or a
movie deal becomes far more impressive and fascinating than any actual talents
you may possess.
That's why every influencer seems to inevitably celebrate earning 1 million
followers by doing something loony as a culture.
We're fascinated by this form of fame,
precisely because it seems to be just one successful Instagram post away.
The logical extension of the democratization of fame that's been going on since
the Renaissance celebrity was once an aspiration to go down in history for your
deeds or to improve your city standing or to secure your kingship today,
fame and the spending habits.
It can provoke amongst fans is the point in and of itself.
This can lead some click hungry influencers to make some very dumb choices.
Every evolution in media has made us collectively more visible.
Being seen by millions has never felt more accessible or more important.
That's likely to continue.
And just as the photograph allowed more people than ever to become more visible
and thus more famous than ever,
it's never been easier to get eyeballs on your face. However,
with each subsequent rise in the number of celebrities,
the entire concept of celebrity starts to become devalued and eye-roll inducing
basically more celebrities means fewer have staying power and nearly all are
faded to quickly become passe in a process that is either sad or sadly
funny, depending on how much of a jerk you are. Now.
We're not saying to quit posting to your dog's Instagram,
but do it for the joy of sharing vandals, sexy mug,
not with the hope of landing her a deal with puppy chow,
but what do you guys think is the contemporary form of celebrity making us all
fame craze monsters, or is the democratization of fame actually empowering?
Even if your last tech doc only got 540 views, let us know in the comments,
thanks to our patrons for all your support staff, that subscribe button,
like at your star on the walk of fame and as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].